[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée un intellectuel engagé qui
était laurent bouvet laure baud été
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
il est le fondateur du printemps
républicain il est mort le 18 décembre
dernier à l'âge de 53 ans il souffrait
de la maladie de charcot est un livre
lui est consacré un livre qui s'appelle
justement laurent bouvet portrait d'un
intellectuel engagé nous allons parler
de lui de son combat pour la laïcité de
ce qu'est la laïcité aujourd'hui avec
deux invités nathalie wolf bonjour alors
je précise que vous êtes tous les trois
vous avez participé à ce livre mais quel
est celui ou vrillière si on peut dire
notez qu'ils votent vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'université de versailles
saint quentin vous avez évidemment très
bien connu leur bové vous avez même fait
des séminaires avec avec lui à côté de
données mayer bonjour vous êtes
philosophe de formation vous êtes et
s'ils souhaitent consultant en relations
sociales et vous êtes l'un des
cofondateurs du printemps républicain
tout à fait et gilles clavreuil bonjour
je vous êtes ancien élève de l'ena vous
avez été
délégué interministériel à la lutte
contre le racisme et d'antisémitisme
et vous êtes aujourd'hui déléguée
générale du club de réflexion l'aurore
et vous êtes aussi un des cofondateurs
du printemps républicain alors on va
commencer ben justement par parler de de
ski et d'autres dans ce livre qui te
plumes en passionnant sur cet itinéraire
on voit comment on est on est des idées
comme on est un parcours on va parler de
justement de ce parcours d'un
intellectuel engagé
[Musique]
alors laurent bouvet et et je disais
enseignant à l'université de versailles
saint quentin c'est d'abord oui fait des
études de sciences politiques qui vont
le mener à l'agrégation de de sciences
politiques donc à enseigner cette cette
matière il a fait une thèse c'est
important de dire sur les états unis
vous en parlez d'un petit peu le thème
de cette thèse à l'envol dire en latin
est pourri booth ou doom
la nouvelle question identitaire déploré
moussa dioum ça veut dire bah un seul à
partir de plusieurs c'est un peu ça
c'est l'église cette voiture lexus sont
dus à l'usure on ne fait rien
on est le même mais il faudra qu'elle
soit publiée ce serait oui c'est
papy
mais ses fondateurs je veux dire dans le
parcours et intellectuelle de leur
prouver oui ses fondateurs parce que en
fait laurent
donc fait une thèse de sciences
politiques en france de philosophie
politique d'histoire des idées et il
fait une thèse sur les états unis et il
va aux états unis la long séjour ce jour
aux états unis et il prend conscience de
du tournant identitaire de la politique
américaine est ce que sa thèse raconte
c'est ça c'est comment les questions
identitaires aux etats unis sont en
train de prendre une place polarise la
vie politique américaine vie
intellectuelle et là le l'intuition
qu'il a à ce moment là de gestion
politique c'est que ces débats là qui
commence à se structurer aux états unis
vont traverser l'atlantique et venir et
venir en france est le dernier ouvrage
qu'il a publié sa peine le péril
identitaire qu'on l'a être dès qu'on a
aidé à tous les trois à mettre en forme
était en fait le jeu le le condensé d'un
plus vaste livre qu'il voulait faire sur
cette question identitaire qui ont été
le prolongement et l'actualisation de sa
thèse notamment sur sur la france et
c'est vrai que alors il faut vous
rappeler sa thèse longue date de la fin
des années 90 donc quand vous dites
wallace et c'est vrai qu'à cette époque
là un joli c'est vrai que ça on parlait
pas encore de fait d'eux des questions
d'identité et encore moins en france et
villeneuve
donc c'est important dans la dans
l'acheminement c'est important aussi
parce que sauzon son maître de thèse
c'est quelqu'un qui compte dans le
paysage intellectuel c'est sûr c'est
pierre rosanvallon c'est pierre
rosanvallon et qu'elle va des
impressions du jury d'agrégation dans
lequel son agrégation et puis aussi aux
états unis vous disiez il va aux états
unis
chicago il rencontre aussi françois
furet intérêts de quelques mois avant la
mort de françois furet mais qui risque
est aussi un personnage important oui je
crois qu'elle deux personnages sont
importants pierre rosanvallon et
françois furet qui à cette époque là au
moment où laurent fait sa thèse on est à
la fin de ce qu'on pourrait appeler la
la gauche anti totalitaire cette période
anti totalitaire où ces deux personnages
qui sont deux fois deux intellectuels
très très puissant deux entrepreneurs
intellectuels ces arrivées vont créer
des écoles ils vont d'un courant de
pensée vont avoir des gens autour d'eux
pense en fait ensemble et notamment dans
là où leur en a fait sa thèse qui est le
centre raymond aron à l'institut des
défunts à l'école des études de en
sciences sociales
et laurent va être à l'intersection de
ces deux parcours qui vont un moment
s'éloigner alors au moment où la la la
la la gauche en tête antitotalitaire va
se va se fracturer au tout début des
années des années 2000 sous l'impulsion
de pierre rosanvallon qui va à un moment
régler ses comptes avec françois furet
avec marcel gauchet avec d'autres
intellectuels avec lesquels pourtant il
avait fait un chemin ensemble et c'est
cette époque là où laurent qui avait
fait sa thèse avec rosanvallon et
s'éloigne va s'éloigner de de celui qui
avait été son goût son premier maître
jeu les liens vous le dit d'ailleurs
dans le dos là pour parler je suis passé
passionne peut-être les gens fassent est
intéressant il ya la mort de pierre
bourdieu et il ya un peu une place de 2
leader de cette gauche intellectuelle
qui est à prendre et que vos comptes
pierre rosanvallon non c'est ça oui
c'est ça en fait
les deux aspects effectivement de la
génèse intellectuelle de laurent bouvet
de ce qu'il deviendra c'est
effectivement la question identitaire
d'un côté de l'autre côté des fractures
de la gauche qui s'est fracturé de la
gauche se manifeste à ce moment-là
apprécié au tournant du siècle
exactement donc au même moment et et
laurent se trouve pris entre ces feux
croisés puisqu'il est à la fois l'élève
de rosanvallon donc
possiblement l'un de ses continuateurs
en tout cas de ce qui porterait sa doit
sa bonne parole mais en fait ils
n'adhèrent pas à ce moment là du tout à
la volonté de rauzan wallon de prendre
des distances très très nette avec les
autres membres de cette gauche anti
totalitaire qui eux ont réinvesti la
question de la révolution française de
ce qu'elle porte le sens de son message
le les penchants autoritaires de la
gauche d'une certaine façon et il va lui
rosanvallon réinvestir la question
sociale vis-à-vis de laquelle il avait
pris pas mal de distance notamment dans
les années 80 90 95 avec la fondation
saint simon qui étaient
suspectées à tort ou à raison c'est un
autre débat mais de de s'orienter de
plus en plus vers le libéralisme
politique et économique de soutenir les
réformes
libérale du mr l'hiver alors de gauche
de droite meilleur mais en tout cas de
les serrer kérékou koné patrons étaient
à l'arrêt ce dossier c'est claude havard
né à un moment donné que ce cas la main
qui avait appelé le cercle de la raison
il y avait là et rosanvallon ne n'est
sûrement pas forcément cette position là
effectivement à la mort de bourdieu
décide en quelque sorte de reprendre le
rôle d'intellectuel organique de la
gauche intellectuelle en essayant de
l'art et unifié autour d'un discours
plus axé sur le social peut être un peu
plus radicale aussi sans pour autant
entrer dans l'est dans les tests de
bourdieu
du tout mais ça va passer en effet par
un procès assez virulent qui va être
adressée
aux intellectuels accusé de dérive
réactionnaire et là vous voyez que les
termes du débat dans lesquelles la
gauche est encore aujourd'hui c'est à
dire assumer une certaine forme de
radicalité au pouvoir en tout cas de
primat de la question sociale versus
s'intéressait aux sujets identitaires au
risque d'être taxé de droite de dérive
réactionnaire de dérive droitière et ses
deux assistants et bien ces débats en
fait ce serait mis en place à ce moment
la série et le rend à ce moment là n'a
pas voulu des rades il y est entré dans
cette voie là dans cette guerre là et
donc il s'est éloigné de rauzan à partir
de là il ya effectivement des
itinéraires intellectuelle qui divergent
même si laurent à ce moment c'est
intéresse aussi à ce qui se passe en
angleterre le est ce qu'il ya une
troisième voie blairiste louis qui
atténue l'air qui arriva en gros une
fente le mur de berlin s'est effondré
une fois qu il peut s communistes et a
disparu de la scène qu'est ce que c'est
la social démocratie comment elle serait
formulée alors c'est là où intervient
l'analyse critique du modèle américain
et l'envahissement de la politique
américaine progressiste par les
questions ayant 10 laird et là
effectivement il signale un danger
mortel puisque l'idée d'un d'un commun
universel commence à être remise en
question commencent à être critiqué
comme étant un leurre en fait destiné à
cacher la perpétuation des mécanismes de
de ségrégation et de domination post
coloniaux voilà donc c'est cette analyse
a cédé la place à ceux à ceux à ce
moment là et qui fait l'objet
en retour de critiques et de très vives
de la part de toute une partie de la
gauche dont effectivement rosanvallon va
prendre le leadership en quelque sorte
et là on arrive justement peut-être
cette division entre de gauche dans
laquelle il va il va prendre parti
puisque yahia en effet ce moment qu'on
pense aujourd'hui un peu fondateur de
l'apparition de de cette étude de terra
nova qui s'appelle quelle majorité pour
la gauche en 2012 et c'est là que et
théorisé l'idée que bras les classes
populaires les classes ouvrières sont
partis c'est le pen auront donc ce n'est
pas la peine que la gauche courent après
mais quand il ya en effet il ya toute
une nouvelle population d'étudiants de
femmes d'immigrés qu'il faut récupérer
ça aussi c'est ses fondateurs sebou et
parce qu'il sait ici opposition aux
essais et c'est ce que la gauche pardon
c'est ce que la gauche socialiste sauf
on va suivre cette préconisation de
terra nova en moins alors elle va le
suivre plus ou moins plus ou moins fait
la personne qui a le mieux suivi la
préconisation de terra nova re ses dix
ans plus tard c'est jean luc mélenchon
lors de la dernière campagne alors il
l'a fait avec beaucoup plus j'ai à dire
et maestria plus de plus de talent que
n'en avait les socialistes à l'époque et
avec un discours qui pourrait être un
discours assez populaire au fond enfin
cesser de mouches clasico ça qu'il ya où
il y a dans
les
l'estrade sociologique identifie terra
nova et dans l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon en 2022 tout un électorat
populaire de gens modestes etc
néanmoins c'est pas l'ensemble de deux
des classes populaires qui pour une
large partie est ce que le rappeler le
sens du peuple
vote vote plutôt pour pour marine le pen
aujourd'hui ou ne votent pas ou ne
veulent ou ne votent et je parle du sens
du pape parce que le colorant publie ce
livre début
et ce livre là va accompagner la
critique que nous allons être quelques
uns autour de autour de laurent à faire
de la stratégie de terra nova en dix ans
le problème de la stratégie de terra
nova qui voilà qui va finalement
j'arrête la stratégie de gauche jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est précisément
d'oublier le peuple ces deux d'oublier
le sens du peuple un peuple qui est
autre chose qu'une coalition de minorité
donc là tout le travail que laurent a
fait sur les états unis voyons grandir
cette question là au sein même du parti
démocrate et de la gauche américaine il
peut le leur et interprétée dans un
contexte français avec une connaissance
fine du parti socialiste et de la
manière dont les choses se passent au
sein au sein du ps se souvient il
c'était c'était au moment du c'était le
grand le dernier grand moment j'allais
dire de
compréhension ou
presque de deux d'acceptation de laurent
et du ps qui était l'université d'été de
la rochelle de 2002 2012 après la folle
la victoire de françois hollande
et ses proches de hollande a alors il a
été bien hollande venu parce que quand
il a été précis beaucoup de revues à la
baisse
une socialiste
et commissionnaires et quand il
s'occupait du secteur international et
donc il a à ce moment là il avait
travaillé
avec hollande il a essayé de l'intéressé
un certain nombre de deux questions
théoriques qui n'est pas vraiment
vraiment arrivé
c'est par quelque chose qui intéresse
françois hollande particulièrement
et donc 2012 laurendon renvoie aux
socialistes en dit ok vous avez vous
avez gagné vous occuper des positions de
pouvoir mais
est-ce que vous avez bien le sens du
peuple et et son discours était très
applaudi à la rochelle je pense que
finalement en fait il n'est pas compris
ses prix
et ça s'accompagne d'un premier
mouvement qu'on a qu'on a fondé on était
plusieurs à fonder autour de laurent qui
s'appelle la gauche populaire la gauche
populaire c'était ça c'était ce moment
là entre 2010 et 2012 de dire si la
gauche contre terre-neuvas si la gauche
veut durablement exercer le pouvoir elle
ne doit pas se couper du peuple doit pas
perdre ce que laurent c'est le titre de
son de son de la voix lasse en août sont
dans son livre le plus profond
le sens du peuple une source du peuple
actuellement et c'est vrai que
mes mais c'est vrai que des réseaux de
la chute de la social démocratie
aujourd'hui c'est un effet peut-être
cette coupure avec aix qui était son
électorat presque presque naturel sur
est quelque chose qui est qui qui part
de loin dès la fin des années afin de
milieu des années 80 et surtout laurent
publié un livre qui s'appelle l'année
zéro de la gauche juste après la défaite
de lionel jospin donc le 21 avril où la
ces questions là il commence à les
matches en retard parce qu'elle commence
à se poser
c'est
de
on sait lui qui disait qu'il avait écrit
le début du discours du bourget où je
suis venu vous parler de la france donc
de la république
la légende que le rang laurent
entretenait jeu j'en sais rien toujours
est il que au moment où cerveau discours
éloge d existence du bourget un beau
discours le donc quelques quelques temps
avant avant l'avant le discours du
bourget il y à un creux dans la campagne
de françois hollande et
et les gens autour de la gauche
populaire sont reçus par hollande et je
me souviens que l'on
arrive est dit est dit hollande si tu me
reçoit c'est que ça doit pas les
discussions irlande 10 mais faites-moi
passé comme ça se fait pour les
candidats moi passer des notes
des haies et et laurent effet passé un
ébauche de discours alors a toujours dit
que j'avais eu le discours que laurent a
fait passer j'ai lu le discours du
bourget laurent toujours dit que le
début de ce coeur du bourget étaient les
mêmes que que ce qui l'avait fait passer
mais bon après il ya beaucoup de gens
qui se sont revendiqués oui voilà
dix heures du bourget
c'est comme le sait comme le discours de
villepin est qu un film là-dessus devant
lui
un mot avant de passer au printemps
républicain peut-être sur la carrière
universitaire puisque
c'est vrai que voilà il dédierait et de
science politique est d'abord à nice il
vient ensuite à versailles saint quentin
une mode la création d'un laboratoire on
lui refuserait yaye plusieurs
malentendus 1 avec l'université oui on
peut dire quelques quelques désaveux du
côté de l'université donc en effet en
laurent est diplômé de sciences po où il
a 21 ans et ensuite devient un maître de
conférences je crois deux ans à lille
ensemble et puis il obtient cette
agrégation qui quand il faut le dire est
quand même très difficile woods a très
peu de postes et vous savez en droit et
en sciences politiques ça reste encore
très particulier l'agrégation et pas
comme dans les autres disciplines alors
il ya une série d'épreuves pendant un an
avec des leçons en loge et la fameuse
grande son qui dure 24 heures on appelle
la leçon dans la façon c'était le thème
c'était le la colonisation la différence
entre la france et les eau pays anglo
saxons il vous dit d'ailleurs ces
paquets d'examen c'est vrai que j'ai un
peu bateau brutalement
et donc de qui là cette agrégation en
six postes il fait partie des six
candidats sont ainsi
passés si reçu et ce qui est extrêmement
peu et
de moins en moins de postes dans toutes
les disciplines en sciences sociales
c'est dramatique et donc il arrive
à nice où il reste une dizaine d'années
avant et bien de se retrouver tout près
d'ici université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et quand ils
arrivent c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident parce que il faut trouver un
laboratoire alors leur ont enseigné la
théorie politique c'est une discipline
qui est très peu enseignée aujourd'hui
en france je crois qu'il n'y a même pas
une dizaine de enseignants chercheurs il
enseigne donc les grandes idées ce qui
permet de réfléchir sur la surface sur
le monde en fait et avec les relations
internationales qui sont pas tellement
mieux lotis fin quand même un peu plus
qui permettent de donner des clés de
compréhension du monde contemporain
finalement se rend compte que c'est pas
les deux disciplines les plus valorisées
on a plutôt valoriser la sociologie
politique où les politiques publiques et
donc laurent doit trouver un laboratoire
et il se tourne vers un laboratoire de
sociologie politique s'appelle le
printemps
tout à fait évocateur qui refuse qu'il
les rejoigne
et on va jeudi on nous les juristes de
droit public et bien accueillir laurent
mauvais au sein de notre laboratoire
donc celle une nuit un exemple mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une sorte de
malentendu
il n'a pas évolué au fondant dans la
note dans sa carrière alors qu'il aurait
pu le faire puisqu'elle était bien placé
pour eux mêmes pour se bourrer cerise
élus et même
ses ennemis pendant quatre ans on n'a
jamais pu être promu
les prix de physique à un faux site
le directeur du cevipof il est l'un des
émirs littéralement et il l'a été
pendant quelques semaines il a même fait
un pot d'accueil je crois oui c'est ça
et puis qui a eu une vente fronde
interne donc ça veut dire que les
langages le cevipof centre d'étude de la
vie politique française et à sciences po
un organisme voilà qui dépend à la fois
de sciences po et du cnrs et qu'on
connaît médiatiquement les versements à
travers les études électorale en
notamment qui le livre hh à quelle
occasion électorale donc pendant très
longtemps il était ce centre était
incarnée par pascal perrineau et pascal
perrineau et je sais c'est amusant
d'ailleurs parce que moi je tente quand
j'ai été nommé l'elysée au cabinet de
françois hollande début 2012 je prends
contact avec un certain nombre de gens
dont pascal perrineau il je pense qu'il
fait ce que faire du jeu quittent le
cevipof et c'est laurent bouvet qui est
quelqu'un de très très bien qui va me
succéder j'en suis très content
l'histoire donc a priori la succession
était engagé et puis patatras en fait il
ya une fronde interne des des
sociologues du cevipof d'un certain
nombre de sociologues qui le récuse et
là des choses vont se dire qu'ils
étaient qui était sous jacente on va
l'accuser de trop être présent
médiatiquement et puis aussi on va
l'accuser comme comme certains
intellectuels ont été les marcel gaucher
et autres l'ont été par en gros la banda
rosanvallon dix ans plus tôt à l'accusé
de dérive droitière réactionnaire
d'obsession anti-islam etc etc
donc accusations dont il va essayer bien
sûr de se défendre mais en étant de plus
en plus accuser
marginalisés mise au banc y compris au
sein de sa corporation et 7 cette
éviction du cevipof on est
l'offre assure aux miens illustration ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
l'université
la recherche est détenu par un certain
clan
je ne sais peut-être dix visites vous de
répondre à ça mais de dire ça comme ça
mais en tout cas on peut penser le
cheikh de ses engagements politiques et
du refus aussi de laurent je crois que
c'est aussi ça le le courage au fond et
le courage dont laurent a fait preuve
c'est l'heureux il a toujours refusé la
commodité des affiliations et ça il le
paye cher
je crois qu'il ya aussi une autre vie
une autre dimension c'est que c'est pas
la cedh il était un notable il refusait
je crois et puis de plus en plus parce
que l'université de l'ue ne donnait pas
l'aider des marques d'affection non plus
de jouer le jeu de l'institution oui
clairement c'était un professeur c'était
un enseignant il aimait ça il l'aimait
les ailiers on l'adoré les étudiants la
villa de rêve français c'est assez
mais ça je voudrais quand même dire
parce que je vis voyant à la formation
et quand on est vice doyen à la
formation on reçoit deux fois par an les
étudiants qui viennent rapporté ce qui
s'est bien passé avec les enseignants ce
qui s'est mal passée et les éloges au
tour de laurent et elle anime un
vraiment au moment de la
la mort de laurent on a reçu un nombre
de témoignages d'étudiants et puis c'est
ce qui avait été dit aussi quand on a
fait un petit local afin d'aller fêter
les étudiants et les collègues et le
personnel administratif et élan on
disait de lui fin j'aurais pas dû
vraiment ce que disaient les étudiants
s'étaient le meilleur des étudiants
qu'on ait jamais eu donc ça dit quand
même quelque chose et je crois que c'est
important de ce professeur senio oui les
enseignants pardon
c'est important de le dire parce que moi
j'ai pas de réseaux sociaux mais je
crois que sont les réseaux sociaux son
image a pu être largement dégradés j'en
ai vu quand même quelques extraits je
crois que c'est important de le dire
aussi pour comprendre voilà quel homme
il était quel enseignant chercheur il
était brillant mais aussi autant aimé
des étudiants des étudiants qui l'a
énormément accompagné
de quelles que soient leurs diverses
vers dvi dual mort va y avait aussi
beaucoup de
l'enseignant chercheur n'ont pas cette
considération et pour le font souvent
passer la recherche avant ce temps
consacré aux étudiants je crois qu'il
est important aussi de le souligner
parce qu'il était un enseignant
chercheur
extrêmement investi impliqué aux 500 son
université moi je découpais pas énorme
et c'est
justement ça faisait partie aussi des
gens sur b ça vous êtes arrivé à lui à
vous puisque vous étiez des cordes les
co organisateurs
il ya eu tariq ramadan qui a été reçu à
sur ce passage avant je crois
il a protesté vous avait protesté alors
non pas moi parce que je ne crois pas au
courant et jeune enseigne
la science po saint germain en laye
alors c'est vrai que ça se fait partie
en effet de tous les tous les paradoxes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés est en
effet lors des rencontres organisées à
sciences po saint germain en laye par
les étudiants tariq ramadan a été reçue
sans son contrat lecteurs donc on est
quand même à faire un prédicateur on a
montré les dangers qui d'ailleurs en
prison est donc ce tariq ramadan ait
reçu
laurent bouvet est le seul à prendre la
parole pour s'opposer et montrer les
dangers de tariq ramadan même à
galvaniser un amphi et seuls deux
collègues vont le soutenir alors là
faire ensuite mal tourné parce qu'il ya
eu un tweet bon à dire sans nuance de la
part de tva ce que mon cru dans ce qui a
généré une wii c'est vrai que parfois il
y avait quoi
ils étaient finalement assez court a
lieu p2 saint germain en laye mais l or
et l autre partie quand vous recevez
pascal bodmer
ici ici même à saint quentin alors il ya
de l'adasea hurle alors là c'est la sens
inverse donc nous recevons pascal
bruckner à l'occasion d'un séminaire que
nous organisions qui portait sur sur la
laïcité on invitait toute une série de
personnalités du monde politique
intellectuel des collègues pour débattre
discuter de ce sujet de de la laïcité et
lorsqu'on invite pascal bruckner on
reçoit des messages de collègues
d'autres du fr nous indiquant qu invité
pascal bruckner à débattre de sujets
autour de la question du terme
d'islamophobie revient à inviter marine
le pen et que cela porte largement
atteintes aux personnes ensevelies mais
le site racisées est donc bon
heureusement on a un doigt y en dans
notre faculté
et les doyens précédent elle était aussi
extrêmement vigilant et attentif à ce
que la liberté d'expression soit garanti
dans nos universités et qu'on puisse
avoir certainement de sujets de
discussion surtout avec des des hommes
et des femmes républicains et démocrates
mais bon voilà voilà où on en est quand
même qui montre que qu'il existe en des
pressions de la part de certains
collègues ou de certains groupes
d'étudiants auquel il faut résister et
auquel laurent faisait face avec là
encore un courage et on est dans le
débat évidemment il y passe extrêmement
bien passé non mais on est d'alger dire
dans le terreau et au grand public ça
peut porter atteinte à des personnes
racisées etc on est dans un débat
justement c'est important et ce qui se
développe à coeur de laurent de ce point
de vue là c'était qu'on était plus dans
le débat qui avait une volonté
d'interdire et d'empêcher le débat en
jetant des anathèmes sur des personnes à
partir de choses totalement sa brique
est inventé c'est à dire partir du
moment où l'étiquette islamophobes ou
identitaires ou extrême droite était que
les bons c'est lé plus besoin
d'argumenter en fait il s'agissait juste
d'interdire de protester de faire du
bruit et de d'exclure de stigmatiser
dans le cas de pascal bruckner par
exemple il a écrit un essai qui
s'appelle un racisme imaginaire on peut
tout à fait débattre de ce qu'il ya dans
le nord mais il est absolument pas tant
quand on lit ce livre avec un minimum
d'honnêteté intellectuelle est pareil
bien sûr pour les travaux de l'an qu'il
n'y a strictement rien à voir avec les
places de l'état - au contraire ils
trient s'y opposait très explicitement
donc voila et et celle ci théâtre ont
été extrêmement apaisé eu des
discussions des désaccords en des
étudiants tout à fait opposés oui
je vous aime interdiction du débat c'est
ça le fond des discussions la question
on va passer à la fondation du printemps
république parce que vous avez clé des
cofondateurs donc c'est intéressant de
savoir pourquoi ce mouvement a été créé
[Musique]
alors pourquoi pas
trompeuse car il devait
prendre la fondation du printemps
républicain il faut voir à quel moment
situe
peut-être définit ce qu'est le printemps
républicain c'est une une association un
mouvement politique de plus en plus
politique qui
cherche à unir toutes les personnes on
vient majoritairement plutôt de la
gauche ça dépasse ça dépasse le clivage
gauche droite
autour des valeurs républicaines alors
notamment la laïcité mais pas seulement
l'état les toutes les questions
notamment sociales
et pour faire
valoir
lorsque ce que ce que pourrait être son
appel à un commun républicain cirque à
skis qu'est ce qui nous tient encore
ensemble ce qu'elle est le cadre dans
lequel
avant de disputer de savoir comment on
partage la richesse ou si on est
d'accord ou pas avec telle mesure il
faut rappeler le cadre le garden main
dans lequel nous vivons l'escadron comme
un français la république c'est les
valeurs républicaines et c'est notamment
la laïcité mais
laurent au moment de la fondation du
printemps républicain avait fait un
discours à la fin donc avait un effet un
grand événement dans le 20e
arrondissement là à la bellevilloise où
il a dit on fonde le printemps
républicain on ne font pas le printemps
laïque serre que la laïcité est un
excellent week-end alors si je reviens
sur le moment de fondation on ne prétend
républicain n'est au début de l'année
2016 et donc on est juste après 7 années
terribles de desbiens attendant les
attentats de janvier et ceux du sud que
13 novembre et que les réponses
qui ont lieu à côté des réponses
sécuritaires qui ont été qui ont été à
la hauteur les réponses intellectuels
politiques se sont se sont largement
largement chercher et notamment on a pu
voir des coalitions de personnes assez
hétéroclite qui n'avaient pas forcément
la laïcité comme comme boussole ou une
laïcité de qu'on pouvait largement
largement discutée est ce qu'on a voulu
faire avec le prato républicain c'est
d'abord unir toutes les personnes qui se
sentaient un peu orpheline isolé dans ce
moment là pour les unir pour dire que
cette année 2015 devait déboucher sur
une initiative politique et de
fondations voir leurs fondations de
mouvement autour des valeurs
républicaines on se situe à à ce moment
là
oui c'est vrai une 2015 et les réactions
aux attentats c'est assez fondateur de
l'un des éléments des
fat il y aura pas eu charlie aurait pas
eu le prendre et de l'oubli car c'est
complètement lié est au fond le
printemps républicains à lui vocation à
recueillir
j'emploie volontairement ce mot là
tous les orphelins de charlie et tous
ceux qui ont senti à un moment de leur
vie que là il y avait un point de
bascule ou leur
leur identité personnelle d'une certaine
façon rencontre elle la grande histoire
l'histoire dans sa dimension la plus
tragique la plus épouvantable et que
quelque chose de ce lien là et d'être en
train de se défaire au niveau d'une
nation tout entière puisque au moment de
sursaut et d'unité qui a été le 11
janvier a très vite succédé à nouveau et
de manière amplifiée
des critiques redoublent en 116 contre
le modèle français est plus la menace
terroriste était forte et plus les
critiques portées contre
la république ses valeurs ses grands
principes se faisait entendre et plus
les républicains se mettaient de même
sur le reculoir se faisait timide et
discret parce que les attaques étaient
de plus en plus vivre comme si quelque
part le récit selon lequel tout ça
c'était un peu de notre faute qui était
en train de s'imposer et la création du
prato républicain c'est de se révolter
contre ce à raison mais c'est absurde et
c c'est une réécriture scandaleuse de
l'histoire on c'est pas ça qui s'est
passé c'est l'inversé c'est une attaque
extrêmement violente contre nos valeurs
contre nos principes contre la liberté
contre la démocratie contre les
minorités
l'attentât de l'hyper cacher contre les
droits des homosexuels contre les droits
des femmes bien sûr et ce mouvement là
qui va au delà de 2 du seul danger
terroriste bien au delà ce mouvement-là
est en train de se normaliser
peut-être pas au point de gagner la
partie mais au point certainement en
tout cas de fracture et la société
française puisqu'il a son pendant de
l'autre côté qui est l'extrême droite
qui profite de ce de ce scénario
conflictuelles et agonistique pour
imposer ses thèmes identitaires à lui en
disant vais regarder bien c'est la
france éternelle qui est attaqué mais
alors donc c'est pas la france
républicaine dont parlait denis tout à
l'heure l'aiic universaliste
égalitarisme non c'est une france
identitaire il plongeait dans des
racines judéo-chrétiennes complètement
fantasmée et reformulé et donc on s'est
retrouvés on s'est sentis littéralement
pris en tenaille entre les identitaires
d'un bord qui défendent les minorités
est le discours néo colvin des colonials
qui va petit à petit se structurer à ce
moment là et les identitaires de l'autre
bord c'est-à-dire l'extrême droite voilà
qui les républicains au milieu se
sentant comme pris en tenaille et est
finalement interdite parole part à la
fois par farouche volonté d'indépendance
dont laurent était un assez bon
illustrateur mais aussi dans la volonté
farouche de rester dans la nuance est de
ne pas tomber dans les caricatures et et
la prise de parti un peu comme quelques
siècles plus tôt le ce qu'on appelait le
parti des politiques pendant les guerres
de religion voulait se tenir à égale
distance des ligueurs d'un côté et du
pays protestant de l'autre les nous la
ligne de crête temps avait alors c'est
l'expression elle avait été prononcée
par elisabeth badinter laurent l'avait
reprise à son compte et effectivement le
printemps républicains se tient sur une
ligne de crête entre ces deux mâchoires
delà de la thonaille identitaire de la
milice entre charybde et scylla
c'est enfin j'espère aussi un peu
l'histoire de la laïcité
il y avait eu l affaire du voile de
creil avait suscité des débats mais
jusqu'au fond jusqu'aux attentats 2015
en rouge c'était plus une question
essentielle
ainsi quand même je dirais que
la laïcité débat oui
cette forme alors c'est un peu la
laïcité c'est vraiment la forme
française de la liberté religieuse c'est
comme ça qu'on peut la définir si je
crois quand même qu'à partir de 89 il ya
un tournant majeur est que depuis 1989
la question de la laïcité est revenue
sur le le débat
si on regarde un peu du côté du
contentieux parce que contentieux c'est
un miroir social qui est assez
intéressant on voit que un peu après
l'adoption de la loi de 1905 il ya plus
de il ya plus de contentieux est
vraiment le contentieux des cultes à
partir des années 1920 se tarit un chéri
tu dis apparence
et jusqu'à l'épuré et puis à partir de
1989 et d'ailleurs c'est ce que tu es
laurent dans un celi c'est une année
vraiment importante on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure 89 tu l'as dit tout à l'heure
l'insee la chute du mur de berlin oui
c'est on est quelques années après
l'arrivée au pouvoir des islamistes en
iran
voilà satanique salman rushdie qui est
lui-même issu de khomeiny et parents en
exil pendant de longues années et donc
tout ça ça voilà c'est bizarre politique
est importante tu crois que c'est
important de le rappeler parce que c'est
pas la sphère de cry tout seul confie
c'est vraiment important de l'ada de la
restituer dans ce dans ce contexte
géopolitique plus générale et quand même
des 89 à la sphère de creil va être le
début de discussions de débats
extrêmement violent autour de autour de
la laïcité et puis qui continuent
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui donc je fais pas
mal de décennies finalement que les
choses ont repris après un moment
d'accalmie de un petit mec qu'on va dire
oui d'autant qu'on voit bien que on à la
loi de 2004 une loi de 2010 sur tout
c'est sur toutes ces questions là il
yal'affaire en 2008 de la crèche baby
loup est donc surtout il ya une
accumulation de signes qui nous montre
bien que
les plaques tectoniques voilà son
étreinte sont en train de bouger et que
l'année 2015 est un moment alors l'année
déjà les attentats de toulouse montauban
etc c'est quand même un moment alors
c'est dans une campagne électorale qui
fait que ça ça passe ça passe pas
inaperçu mais en tout cas c'est sûr
c'est pas c'est pas le dire simplement
peut-être auxquelles on ne prête pas
assez attention et arrive l'année
l'année 2015 donc je pense que c'est
c'est toute cette cette période là que
je 2015 viens viens voilà pour le coup
achevée de manière parce qu'ils parlent
cystique et la création du printemps
républicains derrière pour pour
contrebalancer la signer très vite un
porte à faux d'ailleurs entre ces débats
ces controverses très très vive et le
fait que les positions disons
républicaines sont plutôt sur la
défensive
ça c'est pour je dirais le débat des
élites politiques intellectuels etc mais
de l'autre côté la société française
dans son immense majorité est très
attaché à la laïcité
et même très inquiète en fait de ces
reculs possible des attaques qu'elle
subit etc il ya peu de grands sujets
d'opinion dans un pays où on adore se
diviser sur les idées il ya peu de
sujets qu'ils soient aussi consensuel
que leur c'est très très et je pense
d'ailleurs que on en parlera peut-être
mais dans l'évolution de d'emmanuel
macron durant son quinquennat qui
s'était pas vraiment signalé par elle
pour être très ardent sur la laïcité au
début jusqu'à jusqu'à la loi sur le
jusqu'au discours des mureaux qui l'a
précédé l'assassinât de sa mère pattie
green jours plus tard en octobre et puis
la loi séparatisme cette évolution là
également
lié à une prise de conscience que
la laïcité est une composante
essentielle de l'identité collective des
français
voilà plus qu'un principe je ris dans
les choses qui on evra semblent n ya pas
grand mais c
est quand il ya une remise en cause des
interpellations et des critiques en fait
on s'aperçoit qu'elles sont très
localisés à des milieux politiques aux
militants mais finalement ce sont des
voies très minoritaire qu on entend
énormément parce qu'elles sont très
sonore mais dix sont très minoritaires
il s'est fait pendant près d'un siècle
où il est il est très fort et
on voit aussi ça c'est intéressant que
c'est toujours à l'école que commencent
à ressurgir la question ça a été le cas
et dans ce bras de fer qui est qui qui
se joue avec les islamistes inquiète de
fragiliser les institutions et voilà où
il ya une fragilité envoyer certains
sentait comme chez les enfants et est un
instrument est absolument n'a pas réussi
donc on va aller sur le terrain de la
voie publique avec la question d'amour
car on va aller s'enterrer à l'anthrax
assez c'est assez
la laïcité aujourd'hui un poste
important
parlerons la laïcité aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors avant de vous interroger je veux
voir le tout petit extrait c'est un
témoignage d'un des collègues de leur
prouver et qui s'appelle thomas dean de
man qui est d'origine allemande qui est
professeur de sciences politiques aussi
l'université de versailles
du super six et là justement et son
regard un peu de personnes venant
d'allemagne sur la question de la
laïcité
c'est vrai qu'il ya en france
traditionnellement ce clivage gauche
droite autour laïcité qui normalement a
été occupé par la gauche en allemagne il
ya beaucoup moi ça donc on peut très
bien être de gauche
engagée pour le catholicisme le
protestantisme bon pour moi ça reste un
débat un petit peu étrange mais qui a un
peu catalyser le débat en france depuis
toujours c'est vrai que ça peut paraître
un peu étrange c'est une spécificité
française comme m c'est spécial à la
laïcité telle qu'on n'en parle c'est une
spécificité française lier les gilles le
rappelait en parlant des guerres de
religion à une histoire longue de la
france et du poids du du catholicisme je
crois de néanmoins qu'il ya deux
éléments d'abord un la séparation de
l'état d'un côté et des églises et la
liberté de conscience nous semble-t-il
quand bien même on appellerait pas
laïcité comme on l'appelle en france est
présent dans tous les pays les pays
européens ça c'est une chose et d'autres
lots l'autre l'autre aspect c'est que
derrière nos débats là sur con qu'on a
sur la laïcité la question qui se pose
en réalité c'est comment une religion
relativement neuf dans
en europe à savoir l'islam
s'acclimate à un continent qui
politiquement a fait de la séparation de
ces deux ordres spirituel et temporel
un des fondements de son de son être
politique et comment finalement
l'islam n'est alors plus largement pas
seulement en europe mais dans le dans le
monde de monter notamment dans le monde
arabo musulman
ce est percuté par la modernité et
et ses salles et qui statuent plus dans
le monde arabo musulman que quand on en
trouve un mail aux cocons guide salle et
vous donner une vraie question mais
je dis ça parce que c'est vrai que
laurent bouvet enfin où le printemps
république a parfois été accusé même de
fascisme ça fait rêver les monteverdi
fondation ecobank est fashion east et
c'est vrai que eric zemmour par exemple
visible à l'islam est incompatible avec
la démocratie qu'elle a dit ça c'est
important de dire quelle est la
différence entre eux quand on vous dit
ça pose un problème
et est ce que dit quelqu'un donc posé
autour de l'extrême droite alors là
dessus je je
moi je ne dirais pas et eux ils
printemps a plus qu'à ne le dit pas non
plus que l'islam est incompatible avec
la démocratie de toute éternité
substantiellement etc c'est il ya des
conditions politiques y a des il ya des
conditions historiques et il ya d
acclimatation
leu leu leu le génie français ont à dire
si on peut aussi on peut dire ça comme
ça le génie politique français un peu
c'est d'avoir d'avoir fait une société
enfin là où l'état a fait une société
qui fait que les français sont des êtres
politique et ils peuvent avoir une
identité politique et là dessus on va
retrouver les questions de laïcité de
valeurs républicaines et des identités
éventuellement multiples qui déborde le
le lettres lettres politique ce que
défend zemmour c'est une france ramenée
à une solaire civilisationnel à lille
plus elle qui plus est catholique
historiques etc on est allongé tous sur
les mêmes sur les mêmes chaussures
beauxis fait dans un serveur donne de
préciser ce qu'est ce qui fait que dans
un dans une conception républicaine
l'islam a tout à fait sa place mais la
place qui est réservé aux religions et
c'est ça que la propulsion prend un peu
de recul celis le travail que doivent
faire les musulmans les intellectuels
musulmans les religieux etc le travail
qu'a fait le catholicisme pendant
alors ça a pris du temps pour trouver
une place une place qui leur soit propre
l'une des critiques aussi con on fait
parfois la laïcité c'est que l programme
sahin être un peu hors du temps et qui
ont des droits les goûts et qui
justement en fait une critique qui
sous-estiment balle est d'aider les
inégalités qui peuvent leur être induits
par auno fait la provenance la
provenance géographique la race
l'immigration etc
c'est amusant parce que autant certaines
idées
notoirement né à gauche ont eu tendance
à virer à droite à travers le temps le
patriote iddri djelic mans et bien la
critique de l'abstraction républicaine
c'est le contraire c'était à l'origine
le coeur même de la critique
contre-révolutionnaires dix ans la
république nous invente un être abstrait
mais ça n'existe pas on l est et il n'y
a pas de citoyens
ça n'existe pas les les hommes sont
enracinées ils ont une histoire ils
maintiennent à une terre a une famille à
une religion ce sont des êtres situer
cette critique était le coeur même de la
critique contre-révolutionnaire ça l'est
toujours d'ailleurs parce que finalement
ce que dit zemmour c'est pas très loin
de ça non plus dit nous sommes nous
sommes d'abord des êtres charnelle nous
sommes nous sommes les fils de notre
patrie de nos ancêtres nous d'une terre
qu'ils étaient rares chrétien c'est la
thématique de l'enracinement mais le
discours qui s'est développée qui est un
peu la rhétorique qu'on dit aujourd'hui
works et le terne est imprécis et
polémiques peu importe mais qui reproche
à la république
de ne pas tenir ses promesses une
philosophe qui analyse très bien les
choses c'est stéphanie rosa qui
spécialistes de l'époque des lumières
des de la philosophie des lumières et
qui dit au fond il ya deux types de
critique de la pensée des lumières et
donc son prolongement qu'est la fille de
l'un de ses prolongements que la
philosophie républicaine soit on lui
reproche d'être perfectible c'est à dire
de ne pas tenir toutes ses promesses
mais c'est au nom de ces mêmes promesses
qu'on critique la république disant
c'est juste et pas assez égalitaire elle
maintient un ordre
bourgeois derrière le par devant le nom
de l'égalité des droits mais là c'est
pas ce type de critiques qu'on entend
aujourd'hui c'est une critique beaucoup
plus radicale qui comptent qui
contestent le principe même au fond de
l'égalité républicaine 110 ans tout ça
est une vaste supercherie qui n'a jamais
servi à rien d'autre qu'à asseoir et à
perpétuer alors une domination qui dans
le langage marxiste aurait la domination
de classe mais qui aujourd'hui dans le
langage des colonials est une domination
de type racial et coloniale
voilà cette évolution que je tiens quand
même à signaler parce qu'au fond il ya
un parfait miroitement entre ce discours
qui se prétend que se positionne plutôt
aujourd'hui à la gauche de la gauche et
un discours réactionnaire qui est plutôt
celui d'un zemmour voilà c'est pour ça
que ça soit c'est bien voilà il ya une
profonde identité des identitaires de ce
point là en tout cas dans les raisons
pour lesquelles il critique le modèle
républicain ce n'est pas une question
politique et le nouveau gouvernement
de d'elisabeth bornes on a beaucoup
derrière le départ de notamment de jean
michel blanquer on a beau de codic bas
le printemps république tchèque soutenue
en gros mc oui oui bon on va dire ça et
fessionnels a
été un peu oublié dans ce dans ce
gouvernement c'est votre sentiment ou
pas d'hier
n'a pas apprécié neuf cantons ai
beaucoup pensé penser au printemps
américain mais bon les choses sont pas
encore totalement totalement figée des
élections législatives y aura sans doute
d'autres d'autres nominations et puis
je crois que
le conduire le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron va être va être comme son prince
et du précédent quinquennat
parsemé de difficultés de crise de
choses comme ça
dans le premier 1 sur la question de la
laïcité de la part de mâcon lui est
amené à la vraie question qui va très au
delà de notre de nos modestes personnes
c'est de savoir avec puisque le son
slogan de campagne c'était avec vous
avec qui emmanuel macron en
envisage-t-il de diriger la france
pendant cinq ans non pas au sens des
casting ministériel ou autre ou ou
parlementaire c'est pas le sujet mais
avec quels ressorts dans la société
française compte-t-il lui-même trouvé
une dynamique pour faire un deuxième
quinquennat qui ne serait pas que la
répétition du premier et on ne peut pas
être dans une logique du moins c'est
notre analyse on peut pas être dans une
logique
disons de marché qui consisterait à dire
il ya des clientèles qui expriment à un
moment donné un certain nombre de points
de vue au moment où elles se font
entendre un peu plus fort que d'habitude
on leur donne raison mais ça n'en porte
pas forcément
une dynamique un mouvement non sens ce
qu'on a essayé de poser et qui était
très cher à laurent comme idée et c'est
que une société ça fonctionne pas comme
ça ce ne sont pas des coalitions
d'intérêts de minorités d'opinion de
conviction qu'on est ça qu elle auquel
on essaye plus ou moins de satisfaire de
répondre selon les selon l'humeur du
moment c'est un ensemble qu'il faut
qu'il faut tenir ensemble salamat soit
réalité cette fabrication de l'unité est
aujourd'hui le constat que nous faisons
c'est que le pays est très divisée à
nouveau s'est senti c'est son histoire
c'est notre histoire l'histoire de
france à travers cette conflit et donc
on les gobelins et voilà comment
le président de la république réélu
compte-t-il s'y prendre pour résorber
ses fractures c'est ça le vrai enjeu
pour moi l'enjeu principal de ce
quinquennat le fait qu'elle est une
formule pour rebondir ce que dit gilles
disait on ne doit pas faire la politique
de sa sociologie
mais on doit faire la sociologie de sa
politique derrière qu' il s'agit pas de
deux de se dire s'ils votent pour nous
un tel intel intel et on en donne ici
peu chacun pour ce qui est du
clientélisme et notamment il sait quand
il a vu proposer cette formule
s'adressait aux socialistes ils leur
disaient alors c'est simple on va
solférino la salle marie-thérese eyquem
et puis on dit bon alors on va donner un
peu aux profs un peu aux femmes peuvent
pas et c'est donc ça faisait rire tout
le monde blanc il joue peut-être pas
assez compris ce qu'il était voulait
dire mais par contre il faut faire la
sociologie de sa politique c'est à dire
pouvoir rassembler autour d'une
proposition politique des groupes épars
et c'est ce que vient de dire j tu sais
comment faire tenir tout ça tout ça
ensemble je veux pour preuve d' affaire
du burkini de la sphère de de grenoble
puis les daaf un burqini donc il était
autorisé par le maire de grenoble eric
young dans les piscines ya eu un premier
jugement du tribunal administratif qui a
cassé cet arrêté vous y êtes intéressé
sujets
qui m'intéressent effectivement
interdit est autorisé mais c'est
important comme ça l'était en 2010 quand
on tue évoqué tout à l'heure denis la
question de la burqa à l'époque on a des
gens qui dira monsieur pas grave c'est
juste un millier de femmes ça n'a pas
tellement d'importance et finalement on
a on a adopté une loi qui interdit la
dissimulation du visage dans l'espace
public et c'était très intéressant parce
que à l'époque on s'était demandé mais
voilà comment faire pour interdire ce
type de tenue et sur quel fondement et
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que ce
qui a été mis en avant sa pas été
tellement la question d'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes ça pas été
tellement la question de la sécurité
comme révolue le conseil d'état qui
était très réservée sur sur le sur
l'interdiction mais ce qui a été mis en
avant c'est le respect des exigences
qu'une société se donne à un moment
donné des exigences minimales donc pour
vivre en société
on vit à visage découvert le visage je
sais c'est ce que disait le philosophe
levinas 1 c'est le rapport à l'autre et
accéder à l'autre c'est pouvoir voir et
être vu et et c'était ce qui s'était dit
là ce moment là et c'est exactement
finalement les mêmes débats qu'on a
aujourd'hui autour du burkini on a eu
ces questions qui sont posées à propos
du port du burkini à la plage donc là on
est dans l'espace public et là c'est un
petit peu différent parce que dans cette
dernière affaire il s'agit du port du
burkini dans un établissement public
chargé de gérer un service public est
alors le maire donc de grenoble a adopté
un règlement quand même écrit de façon
hyper bizarre annonce dj pas pris avec
moi interdiction et l'interdiction de
toutes les tenues qui sont pas près du
corps sauf celles qui ne dépasse pas ne
vont pas au delà de la mi cuisse en
effet c'est le burkina qui est visé et
on sait que c'est le burqini la plupart
des burkinis mais une petite jupe à être
inquiets associé à la à la combinaison
est donc le maire de grenoble indique
expressément dans le reconnaît
expressément dans son règlement il
s'agit de permettre le port donc du
burkina alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que le préfet a
alors il le préfet vous savez dalila
depuis
1982 la décentralisation il a un outil
qui s'appelle le déféré préfectoral qui
lui permet quand il estime qu'il ya une
inégalité de contrôler a posteriori un
acte d'une collectivité qu'il estime
être légalement et là on a un autre
outil qui a été créé avec la loi
du mois d'août dernier qui s'appelle le
déférer laïcité et qui permet aux
préfets c'est ce qu'il a fait de
demander au juge administratif de
suspendre
l'exécution de la décision municipale
donc ce qu'a fait le juge administratif
c'est très intéressant parce que il a
donc suspendu l'exécution de l'arrêté
tribune à l'initiative de grenoble à ces
courageux d'ailleurs son président donc
ces trois juges qui ont siégé le
président du tribunal est présent et il
annuler et suspendre
l'arrêté
avec une motivation qui est assez
intéressant parce qu'au fond il se
fondant sur le principe de neutralité du
service public et sur le principe de
laïcité bon elle est très intéressant de
cette décision parce que voilà elle
risque elle peut ouvrir la voie vers
d'autres types de jurisprudence on va
voir ce qui va se passer
là on va voir parce que le conseil
d'état il est très très divisés sur ce
sujet ça va bien dans la dalle est jugé
cette affaire
option 1 il peut faire ça parce qu'il a
il sait le faire très bien de cette
botté en touche ne pas aller sur le fond
c'est à dire qu'il va peut-être trouvé
qu'un procédure justement de ce nouveau
déferré elle est irrecevable on va voir
option 2 il va changer de terrain
peut-être il va pas rester sur le
terrain des services publics il va
plutôt aller sur le terrain de la police
ce qui nous permettra de peut-être sur
le trône en option 3 on va voir c'est de
rester sur le terrain du service public
et de faire un peu comme il l'avait fait
en 89 de dire en soi le port du burkini
n'est pas incompatible avec le principe
de laïcité sauf s'il vient troubler le
bon fonctionnement du service public
donc on va voir moi j'attends la
création sa décision d'ici intéressante
sur le plan de la laïcité des faits
j'avais juste une question pour terminer
pardon à vous poser à tous le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale pap
ndiaye alors il a été critiqué pour une
certaine c'est écrire votre père veut
dire enfin il a fait sa première visite
à conflans-sainte-honorine
là où a été assassiné samuel pâtit c'est
plutôt un bon signe non ben c'est ça le
sens du commun voilà c'est ça oui je
pense que c'était un geste qui a été
appréciée parce que ce qui ce qui fonde
une communauté heureusement c'est pas
toujours des dramas mais enfin là sont
éteints quand même l'assassinât la
décapitation de samuel pâtit par un
terroriste islamiste est un traumatisme
qui reste très vivace
dans le milieu enseignant et plus
largement pour l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative et même au delà
pour pour tous les français donc il a
oui il a eu tout à fait raison de faire
ce geste
voilà à partir de là s'il va avoir
d'autres sujets beaucoup d'autres
virilité autrement main lourde à traiter
mais c'était important en effet comme un
symbole merci merci beaucoup gilles
clavel merci beaucoup de télé wolf et de
dimaga bat voilà pour tout ce que
passionne c'est question de la laïcité
des des grands départs je revois ce
livre laurent bouvet portrait d'un
intellectuel engagé 7 aux édition de
l'observatoire merci merci à tous les
trois merci
[Musique]